[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
commerce extérieur il y a urgence pour
nos entreprises
en 2022 la balance commerciale de la
France a dépassé la barre des 174
milliards d'euros de déficit
ce constat résulte de 40 années de
politique allant dans le sens de la
désindustrialisation du pays d'une
fiscalité trop lourde et d'une
complexité administrative qui ont
conduit les entreprises françaises à
créer des filiales à l'étranger plutôt
qu'à exporter
conséquences de ce déficit la France est
dernière de l'Union européenne en termes
de compétitivité il faut une stratégie
publique pour soutenir nos entreprises à
commencer par les PME les petites et
moyennes entreprises et les ETI les
entreprises de taille intermédiaires
c'est pourquoi la délégation aux
entreprises défend une approche
multiseectorielle et écosystémique la
France doit inverser la tendance
accroître ses exportations aujourd'hui
insuffisante et réduire sa dépendance
aux importations car cette situation est
coûteuse et remet en cause notre
souveraineté économique
à cette fin les auteurs du rapport
Florence blatrix compta Jean ingray et
Vincent Segoin formulent 10 propositions
il recommande de définir via une loi
d'orientation économique pour la France
une stratégie à long terme pour établir
les objectifs en matière de commerce
extérieure et identifier les secteurs
les compétences et les entreprises à
soutenir
il conseille de rénover la gouvernance
du conseil stratégique de l'export et de
renforcer la coordination entre les
membres de la team France Export il
préconise aussi de mieux intégrer la
question des services dans la lutte
contre les délocalisations la délégation
aux entreprises complètent ces quatre
propositions stratégiques par 6
recommandations opérationnelles
elle souhaite que la transmission
d'entreprise soit facilité et que le
soutien au PME et aux ETI soit renforcés
pour encourager les relocalisations et
réindustrialiser la France elle incite
les entreprises à chasser en meute pour
peser de tout leur poids hors de France
la délégation suggère en outre
d'organiser une campagne et
d'information sur les offres
d'accompagnement des PME et des ETI
proposés par les membres de la team
France Export
pour accroître la compétitivité des
entreprises françaises en matière de
compétences elle encourage à consolider
l'apprentissage des langues et les
connaissances en économie mathématiques
technologies et commerces international
dans l'enseignement secondaire et
supérieur afin de mieux identifier les
risques de vulnérabilité
d'approvisionnement elle suggère
d'utiliser les données douanières
européennes enfin les rapporteurs
appellent à définir une base de données
françaises qui permettra avec
l'intelligence artificielle
d'accompagner finement les PME
françaises à l'export
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]